Anthony black reminds me of a Scotty  Barnes type reference Wagner type osar  Thompson bounce quickness speed case and  Wallace I've heard a lot of Drew holiday  comparisons Brandon Miller the Wild Card  this draft the idea of him is special  number six Tariq Whitehead five can't  Whitmore and every time I've seen  Whitmore he gets better Nick Smith may  be the most well-rounded guard in the  draft a man Thompson he's like a 6-7  John Moret number two he got scoot  Henderson everybody got to see him on  the national stage in Las Vegas he plays  with the Swagger he's super competitive  this guy could be one of the top point  guards in the league what's the deal  with wembanyama he looks like a 7-4  guard what is this this doesn't exist in  the NBA it doesn't exist in the world  skill wise his spectacular defense he's  spectacular